in our 40 years in television news
award-winning journalist Katie Couric
has been a prominent voice on the
national stage in 2000 she had a
colonoscopy on live TV to raise
awareness after her husband Jay died of
colon cancer
Katie lost her sister Emily in 2001 to
pancreatic cancer now she is partnering
with a new program called with love me
and asked people whose lives have been
affected by cancer what they wish they
had known when they first heard their
diagnosis and it provides access to
guidance and cancer care resources Katie
Couric joins us first on CBS this
morning to talk about that morning that
program good morning good morning nice
to be here with all of you so this
website is very helpful what do you wish
you had known or had when when your
husband J was first diagnosed with colon
cancer well so much you know before I
tell you that Nora you know people who
are going through a cancer experience
whether they're patients or caregivers
really need the support of other
patients who have been there and why I
wanted to get involved in this campaign
is people are telling their stories what
they wish they had known and it will
these stories will not only help help
people but they'll also be a gateway to
the resources that are so needed when
people are embarking on this terrifying
and painful cancer journey because they
work with 13 advocacy groups and there
is support available and hopefully
patients and caregivers will go - with
love me and and get the help they need
and that's the only experience well
going through cancer what do you mean
well it's very I want to help friends
want to be there and well I think unless
you're going through it you really don't
understand what it's like and I'm
younger Jay telling me having cancer is
the loneliest experience in the world
which made me so sad because I couldn't
help him he felt so alone and for
caregivers it's incredibly lonely - the
caregivers that are profiled that
volunteered to tell their stories talk
about they wish they had known the
importance of self care because if you
don't take care of yourself you can't
take care of the patients patients wish
they had known not to be overwhelmed by
all the information online because a lot
of it is missing for me
as you well know and you know so people
really learned from their experiences
and their life lessons I think will help
so many other people who are dealing
with this disease because one person
dies of cancer every single minute in
this country one in three people will be
diagnosed in their lifetimes and I as
you know co-founded Stand Up to Cancer
which is really addressed the research
side we've raised over 600 million
dollars to support scientists but I've
always wanted to really help patients
you see the way I can bridge this
reality what does that mean well I think
with Jay you know I he dealt with colon
cancer stage four for nine months and I
was so afraid that he would think I was
giving up hope or that I was
surrendering to this disease we never
actually had a conversation about the
possibility that he might die and I'm
still haunted by this I'm writing a book
about my life right now I'm revisiting
this experience and I I wish that I had
had the courage to talk to Jay about
what his hopes and dreams were for our
daughters Elly and Kari did watch the
board here did you just avoid it Katie
it is hard to hear I I was so afraid
that it meant that I was giving up and I
didn't want him to give up and I wish
there was a way to help people navigate
these incredibly painful and difficult
conversations painful for patients
caregivers also for oncologists really
tough stuff as you know nor from your
sister and that but and this is your
point you've been to the other side and
you can speak back to people who are in
the middle of it and say I know you want
to be strong for your family member but
you should have this conversation for
both of them yes and I you know I'm so
so really honored to be a part of this
campaign I really applaud Merck for
making these services available for
patients and caregivers and you know
I've started a new company and I want to
work with companies who care about the
same things I care about cancer that
care about environmental sustainability
gender equality criminal justice reform
mental health issues so I'm really
excited to be
able to collaborate with people who want
to do great storytelling that's going to
engage and elevate and really inform
people because honestly there's not
enough of that content being produced
right now journalist Katie Couric is now
entrepreneur yeah it's fun being a
disrupter well you know the media
landscape has changed automatically I
want to sincere I want to ask you about
that because we're now about a year and
a half into the the me to reckoning
has there been enough change no actually
there hasn't I think there have been
some changes congratulations Nora Nora
and I have talked about this so this is
the first time we've talked about it but
I'm so excited for you you know
representation is so critically
important women people of color people
on television need to look like America
and they need to be in leadership
positions the Women's Media Center just
did a study a compilation of 94
different studies and women are still
woefully underrepresented in media in
news entertainment and digital media
I think it's 63% of broadcast in fact
I've got some statistics as of me were
talking about this 63% of TV prime time
news broadcasts feature male anchors and
correspondence 37% are women
since we're more than half the
population that is as actually
ridiculous but what is more heartening
is to see women in leadership positions
all those reasons are in Susan's or in
see all three male shows the executive
producers are now female you know until
they get in decision-making positions
the top tier of leadership in these
organizations we're not going to have
enough parody or representation of all
different kinds of people and in my
company diversity is really really
important to me and your company is
Katie Couric media however if you want a
name you gotta use it right thank you
yes you do yeah I got a newsletter so
before people turn on the CBS Morning
Show they can hang up a bit
wake up people how this works we'll be
right back